christophe giroux poser des questions
donc je vais poser des questions sur
vous en faites à nos trois pirates qui
sont là bas au dessus de benjamin il ya
une vague de force secte au dessus de
jean-michel il ya une fiente de mouettes
audition de jean pascal
il y a les restes de la soupe de poisson
de l'équipage à bord si les poules mal
rien entendu ils se feront à rosy c'est
des questions sur christophe lambert
attention première question
benjamin quel gaulois christophe lambert
at-il incarné au cinéma indices ce n'est
pas idée fixe
mais lorsqu'elle gaulois mais non c'est
quoi vercingétorix et théoriques sans
vélo et à dia sur autrui pour inquiéter
dans astérix le gaulois mais quant à moi
c'est pas possible
mais quand on dit allez-y vent de force
7 c'est parti ah oui mais mais ce soit
roger blum à celanese
sacré
attention question pour jean michel
maire dans quelques clips de quel
célèbre groupe de rock christophe
lambert at il fait une apparition à
tasser ouf
alors oui dans mes jeunes
oui il ya des réponses non ya pas de
répondre à la question dans quel clip de
can't seem un groupe de rock christophe
lambert at il fait une apparition
n'entend pas de richesses alors je
tenais la carrière depuis se formèrent
parker dont paimpol pour vous je dirais
les stones mais bien christophe queen et
oui c'est quid away sais quoi mais là
beaucoup quand même continué perdu
également jean pascal
combien de films comporte la saga
l'honneur avec christophe lambert 3,3
14,4 et rennes c'est carlo et oui c'est
car près troyes 2-1 et qu'il est on ça
tombe pas dessus
ah oui quand même
là c'est vrai je dois pas très à l'aise
ould babana attention on joue pour une
question bonus si vous répondez bien
tous les trois vous gagnez un week end
ans pas bon vous nettoyez vous reposez
vous ennuie attention les shearing est
activée quel a été le premier métier de
christophe lambert christophe tu ne
souffle pas non vous avez 30 secondes
pour trouver quel a été le premier
métier de créatures bien allez-y
non non non non rigolo on peut aller en
prison comme s'il vous plait mr fait une
rumeur non bien de lire non chanteur
c'est possible
les gars n'ont de casseurs de mouna
sepehri les chéris écoutez bien
peut-être qu'il ya la bonne réponse
lorsque vous avez dit en fait christophe
quel a été votre premier métier vendeur
de chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors
[Applaudissements]